il y a GPT qui est avec nous on adore ça
on prépare d'ailleurs un gros prime vous
le savez année 90 vous serez là ça sera
l'équipe du prime voilà donc vous serez
déguisé on chantera on dansera on
regardera des des émissions des années
90 on va revenir tout sur toutes les
années 90 le prime va arriver très très
vite jusqu'au temps que je récupère
[Rires]
[Musique]
l'argent bonsoir tout le monde bien ça
va très bien je suis très content de te
voir mais moi aussi sur le prime c'est
réciproque à fond à fond va y avoir des
trucs très très lo j'ai marqué dans ta
voix tuas tu as des accélérations c'est
réciproque à
fond longtemps animateur en radio ben
oui plus de 13 ans en radio et oui
chaque matin on peut dire Fun Radio quoi
on est comme ça
ok bon vous le savez je remixe tout làd
avec l'intelligencetif radio du tuning
la radio du la radio du tuning et avant
de commencer vous en avez parlé hier
tiens le nouveau président argentin
ravier m et oui il ressemble très
étrangement à quelqu'un qu'on connaît
bien eril prayer ou ça vous l'avez
montré hier c'est le même c'est le gars
c'est le gars c'est le gars et du coup
bah avec l'intelligence artificielle
vous le savez je peux mélanger deux
visages alors j'ai décidé de mixer eril
pryer avec d'autres personnalités
politiques pour les voir apparaître
faudra juste dire la petite formule
magique c'est Walia Walia c'est comme ça
ça déclench alors on commence avec
Nicolas Sarkozi il est là regardez
attention on y va tous WIA WIA
allez-y attention voilà ce que ça
donne on enchane avec
Macron je pense que le résultat peut
être pas mal W on est
parti la est folle franchement c'est pas
mal on dira un vieux chanteur des années
80 on passe mais on dirait prayer en
fait raconter d'histoire Vladimir
Poutine bien s Vladimir Poutine Walia
Walia ah
ouais gar et on dirait un gars que je
connais on dirait un gars que je connais
pourquoi ession c'est toujours la même
photo non non tu veux venir ou quoi on
fin attend on finit avec Donald Trump C
tu vas l'adorer attention W
[Rires]
W on échange de place si tu veux bon on
passe à la de fake news ça je sais que
vous adorez j'invente une info
totalement folle et totalement fausse et
je vais la montrer à des gens dans la
rue et je sais pas si vous le savez TF1
va devenir payant 6, par mois mais ça
plaît pas à tout le monde il faut bien
payer mainger oui oui oui regardez c'est
comment les gens l'ont pris dans la rue
c'est
[Musique]
parti à partir du 1er janvier 2024 il
faudra désormais débourser la somme de
6,90 € par mois pour pouvoir continuer à
regarder TF1 c'est une blague ah non non
c'est sérieux ah oui oui qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez rien vous en pensez quoi
ben payer 6,80 € pour avoir de la merde
je trouve ça compliqué quoi ah ouais
vous êtes cash quoi ben moi c'est pas
mon truc déjà la télé de base c'est pas
trop mon truc je préfère les
informations indépendantes sur
Internet débourser la somme de 6,90 €
par mois ah ou doncer les salaires des
présentateurs et puis comme ça ils font
des économies au revoir TF1 bye bye
ditle là au revoir au revoir TF1 à
bientôt on regardera la 2 M6 C8 C8 ah
ouais C8 vous aimez quoi comme émission
sur C8 an noun vous l'aimez bien ah
beaucoup c'est vrai j'aime bien bah
c'est vous vous avez un message pour
Sirine non cela augmentera bien
évidemment la qualité
de c'est incroyable ouais on sait plus
où on va quoi bah à peine 800000 €
d'évolumement pour franç Hollande et pas
pour et là il veent nous faire payer
pour TF1 bon du coup on regarde plus TF1
quoi vous en pensez quoi de cette
décision euh ben du gros n'importe quoi
c'est vraiment on est parti à volo là
c'est la Guer atomique vous seriez prêt
vous alors moi je serais prêt à payer
6,80 par mois pour virer François
Holland
ou essay de lui dire je mais ilit à une
autre époque je crois il est plus
président sais franis n'est plus
président ouis mais il est V dans une
autre époque il est resté sur François
Hollande bon Cyril je sais que vous
aimez bien chanter et la dernière fois
ça avait cartonné donc on va se refaire
un top 50 pour ceux qui connaissent pas
le principe est simple je prends des
chanteurs de variété français
extrêmement connu je garde leur chansons
je le VO mais je change les paroles ça
donne ça c'est
parti on commence avec le salut les
petit cl bien évidemment bienvenue dans
Top 50 avec en 3è position Daniel bal et
son
[Musique]
titre et à la deuxè place du classement
cette semaine il fait une entrée du
tonner c'est Claude François avec son
titre sappé comme jamais bien les mains
oh les
mains sauf les mecs en
B en B
çaou façon à
la oh ça fait comme
jamais
lououû
je sera ça fait comme jamais al face
dans min je te promet que je vais faire
viv et enfin il est premier depuis 10
semaines consécutives c'est le grand
jean-jaces Goldman avec son album de
reprise de W carton avec le single Ana
ou ça
existe parles AC une
an mais moi en vrai je
m'pp
tu
prends et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de
pourir du coup je me suis dit que
j'allais ref Miss univ version
intelligence artificielle non là j'éta
obligé et bizarrement vous allez voir
que dans ma version on a vu plein de
visages connu
regardez alors j'étais devant ma télé
tranquillement et comme vous le savez la
soirée démarre par les miss qui criaient
très fort leur prénom et quelle surprise
de voir que Raymond était présent
bonjour
Raymond on a eu aussi le droit
mich c'est le meilleur oublié m avec
beaucoup trop de
d beau il est très
beau très beau ensuite j'ai continué de
regarder la cérémonie c'était l'heure
des costumes régionaux et qui j'ai vu
Jacqueline cardos qu'est-ce que j'étais
heureux de la voir à la télé c'est
attention hop
fin
et qui j'ai vu ensuite
erazour on peut avoir un petit retourné
h ah nouvelle carrière et attention
accrochezv voilà celle qu'on attend depu
le début la pépite de
[Applaudissements]
Tun et on finit avec les maillots de
bain oui bien sûr on a retrouvé le
copain du
SPIP c'est les meilleurs c'est les
meilleurs et pour finir la star de la
soirée Jean
Laz merci merci Salut tout le
monde
allez euh merci bchér il est 19h26 on
est en direct